-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Mike Birbiglia.
And not to give too much away
from the show,
but in the title,
a pool is referenced.
And you started
going to the YMCA
to sort of help yourself
get healthier.
-Yeah, and it was funny,
'cause a few years ago,
I was workshopping the show
in New York,
and a lot of the administration
of the YMCA
started coming to the show.
And I talk about how there's
a lot of urine in the pool.
And, like, that's, like,
the main thing I talk about
with the YMCA.
Like, I say, like --
Literally, I say, like,
there was a study
where these scientists
studied a 200,000-gallon pool
and concluded that there was
20 gallons of pure urine in it.
And I said, it's too much.
Percentage-wise,
it's not that much,
but if you picture it,
it's a full tank of gas.
Like, that's a Ford F-150
full of urine.
That'll get you to Pittsburgh.
And the YMCA folks
came to the show,
loved the show, came back again.
They're probably the most
consistent repeat customers
of the show,
which goes to show you --
and I'm sure you've experienced
this with this show
and with "SNL" over the years --
people like being made fun of.
-Yeah, well, they just like
hearing their own name.
I think they're just like,
"This is great."
You -- Like a lot of comedians,
'cause you've been workshopping
this show for years.
During the pandemic,
a lot of avenues weren't open,
obviously, indoor spaces.
What were some
of the outdoor spaces
you were lucky enough
to perform at?
-I was in all kinds of yards
and hotel parking lots.
At one point
there was a train --
At one point there was
a racetrack in Jersey
where I think Mulaney and I
were doing a show one night --
John Mulaney.
And it was actually the --
My agent, Mike Berkowitz,
was there,
and he watched my hour,
and he was like, "I think this
should be a Broadway show."
Which doesn't happen
at the racetrack that often.
-Yeah.
-But the reason why
was because --
Because of the pandemic,
everyone was inside for so long
that a lot of the people
at these shows
weren't even fans of me and John
or even comedy.
They were just like,
"Something's happening
down the road!"
You know what I mean?
And they just showed up.
And it was, like,
kids who were like 10,
people who were like 90,
and they all really liked
this material.
And that's why my agent, Mike,
was like,
"I think this could appeal to,
like, a wide swath of people."
And you even saw it last night.
Our friend Mike brought
his kids, who are 12 and 14.
They seemed to like the show.
-It was fun --
You know, over the course
of the night,
I really did enjoy
looking around.
And I do think this is
a very special week, right?
A lot of families are together.
-Yeah.
-And so this was a thing
they were confident
that all ages would enjoy,
and it seems, like, trite to be
like, "It's fun for all ages."
But it really was,
and I think that was
a cool thing about the show.
-Funny thing -- Like, last week,
there was a kid
in, like, the third row.
And I go, like,
"Hey, how old are you?"
Sometimes if someone's really
young, I like to call it out,
like, "This might not
be appropriate for you."
Like, my last show, I might --
The new one on Netflix,
actually in the taping,
there's, like, a young kid.
Like, "I just want you to know
that I'm not inappropriate.
You just have bad parents."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And so last week,
there was a kid who was --
seemed really young,
like, in the third row.
And I go, "How old are you?"
And he goes
[High-pitched voice] "13!"
And I was just like,
"I don't think so."
And then I was like,
am I, like, carding this kid?
Like, he thinks I'm the bouncer
at the comedy show,
like, "Get out of here!
You're 7 years old!
Get out of here!"
But, yeah, no, it is.
It's not fun for all ages,
but truthfully, like,
I think 12 and up is, like --
it's fun 'cause it's like --
It ends up -- Don't you think
it's a conversation starter?
-Yeah.
I think it really is.
And I also -- I think --
We're about to embark
on our time of Thanksgiving,
which everybody could use,
I think,
a few conversation starters
at Thanksgiving
and maybe some advice.
And you do some have very
helpful advice for Thanksgiving.
-Here's my advice.
I was thinking about
relationships, marriage,
and how --
I think this can apply
to Thanksgiving, which is,
I think in a marriage,
and you --
I've been married 14 years,
and you've been about the same?
-Nine.
-Never mind.
-Yeah.
-We've both been married
about a decade.
-Yeah, yeah.
-And I found that in a marriage,
you got to always remember that
you can't predict the weather.
You never know
how it's going to go.
Always bring a raincoat
and an umbrella,
'cause otherwise, you're just
going to be like, "I'm soaked!
Why am I soaked," you know?
And that's how I feel
about Thanksgiving.
You're going to be
with your family.
And some of them
you're not going to like.
So bring an umbrella.
An emotional umbrella.
-Not a physical one
to just, like, stick them with.
Like, an emotional one.
-That's my advice
for Thanksgiving.
-That's very good advice.
Other advice that I would give
everybody is go see the show.
It's wonderful.
It's always so nice
to have you here.
Thank you so much.
-It's the best.
-Mike Birbiglia.
"The Old Man and the Pool"
is playing at
the Vivian Beaumont Theater
an additional two-week extension
of its run.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."